wir steuern auf einen pflegenotstand zu
und ich glaube was wir jetzt nicht
brauchen ist das klassische politische
blabla sondern wir brauchen endlich
lösungen ich bin seit 20 jahren
politisch engagiert ich kenne das thema
pflege seit 20 jahren und wenn ich mir
die gesundheitsminister anschaue dann
unterhalten wir uns lieber über corona
maßnahmen vielleicht im winter 2025
gerade anstatt mal das problem und die
herausforderung in der pflege anzugehen
und wir steuern darauf mit voller
geschwindigkeit auf eine schlucht zu die
wir
sehenden auges anfahren und da müssen
wir umdenken allein die tatsache dass
wird bis 2035
500.000 pflegekräfte brauchen werden die
wir nicht haben und das ist ja jetzt
beginnt fast 20 millionen menschen geben
jetzt an anfänglichen rente das wird
eine herausforderung und da brauchen wir
dringend lösungen und endlich handlung
also ich kann sagen dass man kann ich
sagen dass dann nur blabla stattgefunden
hat und keine handlungen den letzten
jahren es ist wirklich ein paket nach
dem anderen aber sie haben recht es ist
immer zu wenig und er ist immer
hinterher weil natürlich die bevölkerung
älter wird man braucht immer mehr
pflegeplätze die herausforderung wird
immer größer immer weniger machen es zu
hause selbst auch der anteil ist ja
logisch die frauen sind erwerbstätig die
können zu hause sich nicht mehr so um
ihre eltern oder großeltern kümmern das
heißt das problem spitzt sich immer mehr
zu und ich muss natürlich auch bürger
auch am gehalt einiges gemacht haben ich
bin wirklich ich war ja auch betreuungs
richterin dadurch war ich ständig in
alten- und pflegeheim und bezirks
krankenhäusern seit dieser zeit ist das
auch ein thema das mich wirklich
unmittelbar beschäftigt ich habe
eigentlich als ich frisch im bundestag
bin wollte ich unbedingt ein riesenpaket
dann kam die flüchtlingswelle nach
riesenpaket jetzt dafür gebraucht das
ist ja in welcher situation sie in
alten- und pflegeheim gestoßen also es
hat sich inzwischen wirklich einiges
verbessert was aber definitiv der fall
ist ist dieses bürokratie was für für
die meisten pflegekräfte das schlimmste
ist sie sind auch jetzt wo sich
gehaltsmäßig ein bisschen was getan hat
in den letzten jahren viele die sagen
das gehalt ist das eine wir haben also
zumindest kann ich sagen bayern im
ersten lehrjahr haben die 1000 euro das
ist gar nicht mal so schlecht wie man
kocht wie gesagt also im ersten lehrjahr
ist es nicht mal so schlecht
allerdings sagen eigentlich alle die
belastung schichtdienst viele wollen
deshalb auch als frauen wegen diesen
schichtdiensten nicht voll arbeiten
sondern nur teilzeit die meisten wollen
nur viele wollen nur teilzeit dann auch
dieses nicht wertgeschätzt zu werden das
ansehen des berufes deshalb ist
vielleicht sozusagen diese diese pflicht
da mal reinzuschnuppern auch mal
überhaupt den bezug zu haben zu dieser
tätigkeit das ist für viele nicht schön
auch die abwertung ganz aktuelle wird
jetzt auch als auch gebessert werden
aber trotzdem dass soviel immer noch
haben wir viele erzählt immer muss man
noch warten und der arzt muss extra
komme und was verschreiben aber wir
wissen genau was er braucht oder nicht
mehr kümmern und wir wissen was taugt
also da wäre es sinnvoll wirklich diese
tätigkeit insofern auch aufzuwerten ich
weiß dass man vielleicht die ärztelobby
dagegen dass das alles so zu sagen da
mehr gemacht wird es ist jetzt langsam
im gange da muss bringen weil das sind
eine wertvolle aufgabe und die muss auch
als so wertvoll angesehen werden da gibt
es die forderung nach den
gemeindeschwestern wo man sozusagen
bisschen
unverzichtbar ist für die gemeinde denn
ganz viele jobs werden gemacht wie
verdienen gar nicht mal so viel aber die
haben ein ansehen und die leute gehen da
drin auf und das ist so ein bisschen das
problem dass wir hier haben also
bürokratie fehlende wertschätzung und
vor allem auch arbeitszeiten aber auch
diese nicht selbst eigene harrison seine
frau keller einmal fragen kann ansehen
die miete zahlen ansehen zeigt die
mieten nicht und wissen wir haben jetzt
in der korona zeit haben wir ja auch
erlebt das ist auch immer hieß nach dem
motto man ist das aufwerten und so
weiter stattdessen hat man das ganze
pflegepersonal jetzt mit einer
impfpflicht noch zusätzlich gegängelt
und hat auch welche nach draußen
getrieben das muss man einfach auch so
sagen
ich würde allerdings auch vielleicht mal
ein aspekt in die politik hinein bringen
der völlig vergessen worden ist sie
sagen ja zu recht es braucht sozusagen
immer mehr pflege weil die familie
ausfällt ja weil immer mehr frauen
berufstätig sind was ihr gutes recht ist
gleichzeitig aber wenn wir sagen wir
kriegen wir wo wir wissen ja nicht
einmal wo wir die ganzen leute her
nehmen sollen für die pflege
gleichzeitig gibt es tatsächlich sehr
viele familien die würden gerne pflegen
würden sie das irgendwie kompensiert
bekommen warum nicht endlich die familie
stärken die meisten
ja die meisten
ich kenne kaum einen alten menschen der
sagt ich will wenn ich alt bin in trier
geheim das heißt alle versuchen ja
eigentlich eine lösung und möglichst zu
hause zu bleiben warum können wir nicht
deutlich mehr die pflege zu hause
fördern ich glaube dass wir damit einen
teil der lösung hätten weil es sehr
viele gibt die würden das machen aber
die sagen auch wir brauchen die zwei
gehälter wir wissen nicht wie wir es
machen sollen wenn aber eine familie
unterstützt wird weil sie die großeltern
pflegte oder die alten eigenen eltern
trägt wenn es eine kompensation geben
und das wäre wahrscheinlich deutlich
günstiger als jeder pflegeplatz ein
normaler pflege karlsplatz kostet
tausende von euros und sie könnten
wahrscheinlich für die hälfte die pflege
in
der familie statt wir haben 81 prozent
in der pflege schon in den bei der
angehörigen also wir haben dann großen
teil was ich aber machen muss es
natürlich die pflegenden angehörigen zb
darüber zu reden ob ich dem die
sozialbeiträge zahlen weil das führt
später dann wieder zu einer altersarmut
wenn die keine rentenzahlungen und zu
geschichten haben also ich glaube wir
müssen sowohl die also der heutigen zeit
als auch den professionellen teil sagen
nichts gemacht da ist ein einstieg zwei
schritte auch schon gemacht genau aber
da
ein 2 1 zu stattdessen ein zustimmendes
argument ich war vier jahre in thailand
fast vier jahre als leiter der
konrad-adenauer-stiftung und habe dort
vor meinem hinweggehen mit herrn spahn
ein langes gespräch geführt und wir
haben uns gemeinsam vorgenommen aus teil
1 kräfte hierher zu holen ist es mir
gelungen weil sie in so einem land eine
monarchie mit der diktatur nicht so
einfach ist das bei den
entscheidungsträgern vorzudringen es hat
ein briefverkehr stattgefunden wir mein
konzept entwickelt und ersparen musste
mir dann sagen das ist in der form haben
auf zwei jahre angelegt ich aber nicht
durchsetzbar fünf jahre ist das mindeste
und muss ein konsens hergestellt werden
zwischen allen ressourcen übrigen bevor
wir das zeichen gesetzt wissen sie
bislang ist im gegensatz zur periode
nämlich um der pragmatismus mit dem
andere mit so etwas umgehen ich musste
meinen gesprächspartnern sagen danke
deutschland ist leider nicht fixiert
gutes beispiel und das ist schlecht aber
nicht eine prägende erfahrung